this is the dorkiest movie I have ever
seen okay so essentially Paul is a giant
mix-up of all things dorky Star Trek
Star Wars alien predator Close
Encounters of the Third Kind et the Lord
of the Rings all these films are a giant
inspiration to Paul I just saw Hot Fuzz
over the weekend I loved it it was with
Simon Pegg and Nick Frost directed by
Edgar Wright had made Scott Corum and I
cannot believe that I waited that long
to see it it was very well done it's
about two really dorky guys who are like
super super dorks and when I say that
that means something because I'm a huge
dork myself they're taking like a road
trip across the country to go to various
conventions and UFO sites of supposed to
abductions and things like that and they
run into an actual alien Paul voiced by
Seth Rogen and then all of a sudden
they're on the run from the FBI and the
police and various things and it's just
a huge comedy I had a lot of fun with
Paul Simon Pegg is really funny and him
and Nick Frost have excellent chemistry
together they're obviously good buddies
in real life and they work really well
on screen Paul isn't like a laugh out
loud funny movie but it's just a very
fun entertaining film with a lot of
funny parts all the way through it
really honestly the best thing for me
about this movie was it has such a love
of films that kind of shaped my
childhood like Close Encounters and et
and predator and Star Wars Star Trek and
stuff like that just things that I've
always enjoyed my whole life and this
film obviously has such a love for it
references everything all the way down
to Paul going big-time I was like oh my
gosh the predator that's awesome Jason
Bateman is very good as an FBI agent
there's hot on the trail of Simon Pegg
and Nick Frost
Seth Rogen is really good as the voice
of Paul at first I was like really
seth rogen and then it just really
worked out he just did a really nice job
Kristen Wiig is pretty funny as a girl
who is kind of learning about the world
and she's been very sheltered
simon pegg is always good he's just a
really good comic actor Nick Frost works
really well with him and he is also very
funny all in all this films very funny
lots of great references really good
chemistry between actors and just
overall fun time it's not like a laugh
out loud constantly funny movie it's
just it has a lot of funny parts all the
way through and it's a fun movie to
watch but there you know it could have
been funnier the direction is a little
bit lacking compared to some of their
previous movies that they've worked on
but for the most part this is just a fun
movie a really fun entertaining movie
and I enjoyed it I'm gonna give all
three out of four stars and definitely
feel like a sci-fi dork fan like I am
and you grew up with films like in the
eighties and nineties that just meant
something to you this is definitely your
movie
Jason Bateman is very good as a hot hot
I was trying to say FBI hot on the trail
but I've said Jason Bay with hot so I
guess I'm kind of okay that's interest